so glad that [ __ ] died  never been more excited each night of my  life  that I suck for all of you did he suck  for you yeah he didn't even look at me I  gave him when I was 10 but I've been  meeting all kinds of people in America  right we sucked for you because you said  something I said you look like you read  a lot of books yeah I wish I was reading  how do you guys know each other  you met on hinge yeah dude the south is  more open-minded than you think don't be  so nervous you know what I mean there's  some [ __ ] that you're not nervous  what are you thank you  tell me what emotion you're feeling  you're not trying to power through the  set but when I'm done with my set and I  see him doing this  [ __ ]  [ __ ] and then I just [ __ ] lost it I  was like all my jokes [ __ ] this guy how  is this more polite than just getting up  and walking out [ __ ] grits dude